multiplique y exprese el producto en
notación científica primero
multiplicamos y luego lo expresamos en
notación científica
pero antes pensemos en lo que es la
notación científica la notación
científica es la forma a por 10 elevado
a alguna potencia
y de hecho estos dos números están en
notación científica
donde a puede ser mayor o igual que 1 y
debe ser menor que 10
estos dos números son mayores o iguales
a 1 y son menores que 10 y ambos están
multiplicados por alguna potencia de 10
veamos cómo podemos multiplicar esto
esto es exactamente lo mismo que lo haré
con fucsia
esto lo mismo que 91 por 10 elevado a 6
por 32 por escribir todo con el punto en
vez de la equis para que quede más claro
lo haré confusión
esto es igual a 9
como 1 por 10 elevado a 6 por lugares
con verde
por 32 por 10 elevado a menos 5 en
multiplicación esto es según la
propiedad asociativa que básicamente nos
permite quitar los paréntesis dice que
podemos multiplicar así primero o
podemos multiplicar esto primero los
podemos real social y la propiedad
conmutativa nos dice que podemos cambiar
el orden aquí quiero cambiar el orden
quiero multiplicar 9,1 por 32 primero y
después multiplicar eso por 10 elevado a
6 por 10 elevado a menos 5 aplicaré la
propiedad conmutativa para cambiar el
orden esto lo mismo que 9,1 por 3-2
cambiar el orden multiplicar estos
primero y luego 10 elevado a 6
10 elevado a 6 por 10 elevado a menos 5
es más fácil multiplicar de esta manera
tienen la misma base base 10 así que
para obtener el producto podemos sumar
los exponentes esta parte 10 elevado a 6
por 10 elevado a menos 5 quedará como
quedara como 10 elevado a 6 menos 5 o
básicamente 10 elevado a 1 que es sólo
10 y multiplicaremos eso por 9 1
por 32 lo haré por acá 91 por 32
no tomaré en cuenta la coma los
multiplicaré como 91 por 32 2 por 1 es
22 por 9 18 pongo un cero para cambiar a
las decenas en realidad multiplicamos
por 30 1 por 3 por eso puse un 0 3 por 1
es 3
3 x 9 27 20 es 28 36 11 subimos el 1
11 227 es 9
y queda un 2 91 x 32 es 2 1912 pero no
multiplique 91 por 32 multiplique 91 por
ahora debo contar los números que hay
después de la coma hay 12 números
después de la coma debe haber dos
dígitos después de la coma 1 y 2
pongo la coma esta parte queda como 29
12 podrían pensar que terminamos se ve
como notación científica hay un número x
una potencia de 10 pero recuerden que el
número debe ser mayor o igual a 1 y lo
es
pero debe ser menor que 10 pero este
número no es menor que 10 no es notación
científica
lo que podemos hacer primero expresamos
este número en notación científica y
luego vemos cómo hacer la parte de la
potencia de 10
29 12
es lo mismo que 2 912
se fijaron en lo que hice móvil a como
hacia la izquierda otra forma de hacerlo
que puedo hacer para transformar esto en
eso lo multiplicó por 10 se multiplicó
por 10 debo moverla como hacia la
derecha 29 se transforma en 29 para
expresar este valor lo multiplicó por
día es cierto 29,12 lo mismo que 2,9 12
por 10 ahora en notación científica pero
eso es sólo esta parte a un nuevo
multiplicar por un 10 más
así que por 10 para terminar este
problema tenemos 29 12 por 10 por 10 ó
10 elevado a 1 por 10 elevado a 1 cuánto
es eso esta parte es igual a 10 al
cuadrado
entonces es 2,9 12 por 10 elevado a 210
elevado al cuadrado
29 12 por 10 elevado a 2 y terminamos